foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Piers Morgan on Saturday night
Barbie sets the box of his Ablaze with a
record-breaking opening weekend the face
of the growing backlash for its anti-man
sexism what is empowering women have to
always be about trashing men well
debates Wildlife wildfires rage in
Europe but both of Britain's leading
parties go cold on their green policies
in the wake of the by-election turmoil
Nadine Doris is still a conservative MP
and joins me live
that's British pop rockers The 1975
calls outrage in Malaysia by taking a
public stand for gay rights or a noble
but what were they doing there in the
first place I'll talk live to renowned
philosopher Sam Harris on religion
versus free speech
foreign
[Music]
love it all loathe it Barbie is an
undeniable box office beer moth
Hollywood's spin on the world's most
famous plastic doll baked
377 million dollars on its opening
weekend alone a box office record for a
film directed by a woman or a person
identifying as a woman and the biggest
weekend for movie theaters since
pre-pandemic but it's fair to say not
everybody is enjoying it
premise of the film politically speaking
is that men and women are on two sides
of them and they hate each other all men
in the film are either bigots or idiots
now is Barbie a smash the patriarchy
feminist film yes it is the real world
and all the men in it are shown to be
universally irredeemably horrible
well permanent U.S conservatives are now
calling for a Barbie boycott Barbies
having said Ablaze in the streets as
soon as the Ted Cruz a former
presidential candidate says he's
brainwashing Chinese Communist
propaganda that's got something to do
with flags I think as always I
personally feel a measure of dignified
perspective and restraint is required at
moments like this but also as always I
hate to say I told you so
there are a number of Barbie characters
in the movie right one plays President
Barbie one plays Dr Barbie one plays a
Barbie with a Nobel Prize in physics one
is a mermaid Barbie however all the male
characters in Barbie world are simply
called Ken so it's pretty clear where
this movie is going this is an assault
on not just Ken but all men well I
wasn't wrong was I and it's even worse
than I feared the core focus of Barbie
is oh God the patriarchy
the word is used endlessly in the movie
even though most people really me
actually have no real idea what
patriarchy really means
I guess it means all men are evil so
they can prove otherwise women are their
oppressed victims anyone disagrees it's
obviously a misogynist Barbie's message
isn't the only solution to all this
Dreadful patriarchal instead of Affairs
is obviously for women to rule the world
preferably do so on their own with that
horrible men to ruin it or ruin them in
their lives so they want to do it on
their own there's a slight genetic
problem with that though
what happened in like 100 years it's all
over if there is a plot it boils down to
something like this Barbie lives in
Barbie world with many other virtues
living Barbies including a transgender
Barbie a disabled Barbie and a black
female president Barbie these Barbies
are all powerful while the Ken's
obviously are all second class useless
half-whits then Barbie and Ken are
transported to the real world where wait
for it men are in charge of everything
and are largely despicable Barbies
immediately objectified one ghastly man
shouts give us a smile Blondie which is
a phrase that hasn't actually been used
in the real real world it's in probably
the second world war Mattel the owner of
Barbie is represented as a macho
misogynist outfit with an all-male Board
of alpha dogs the unfortunate reality is
that Barbie was invented by a woman
called Ruth Handler who ran the company
for 30 years as president until this day
Mattel has five women on its 12 person
board now without spoiling all of the
movie all these stun in conclusion he
does all that for himself of course Ken
returns to Barbie world filled with
patriarchal malice prompting a battle of
a sexism which all of the empowered
Barbies have to unite to defeat the evil
idiot Ken's my question about all this
is why
can we just get along I thought feminism
was about equality what is empowering
women always have to be about trashing
men
the real world I live in is full of
confident High achieving women who
probably will laugh at such a derisory
misrepresentation of their supposed
lowly status in life compared to men and
if anybody made a movie which depicts
women as Barbie depicts men well they
wouldn't just be canceled they'd be
tired and feathered and marched through
the streets were to debate the Barbie
backlash islamicut the director of
matriarch and here in the studio
lifelong Barbie fan Esther cracker who I
had to say looks absolutely fantastic
you look that's a look you should keep I
mean we can all agree on this uh also
join my socialist uh and author so
should we can be a socialist author
Ashley Rose Blakely who came his Barbie
last week to be fair but has not got the
memo today plus appropriately stuck in
the middle of his strong female panels
Chris Taylor who plays one of the Kens
in the actual movie which is now one of
the biggest movies of all time and he
was in love Island so I may have to
finally concede that somebody connected
with love Island they've actually done
something with himself an incredible
moment of realization and self-awareness
well thanks for joining me everybody
before we get down to some serious
Barbie related to debate I want us all
to feel comfortable
let's go party
there we go well now in Barbie World
um okay where do we start here let's
start start with you Esther because you
look fantastic and you saw the movie
today I've written a column for the sun
and the New York Post actually same
column
when I hear the word patriarchy as often
as it said in this movie immediately I'm
like here we go again here we go again
this sort of construct that or despite
everything that's happened in the last
50 years all men are awful till they
prove otherwise all women are
downtrodden oppressed and if only it
wasn't for ghastly men they've been
ruling the world you know Lily Allen
said she went to see Barbie and
Oppenheimer and the clear conclusion was
if women were in charge none of that
would have happened right I mean it just
it is exhausting to me I mean I could I
suspected this would happen when we
started having a conversation about
whether Barbie is a feminist icon and I
just thought to myself why does Bobby
need to be a feminist icon anyone who's
grown up with Barbies knows that she's
just a door that girls like to play with
and then 10 seconds into the film I'm
just being shoehorned with this ideology
this you know patriarchy nurse and
feminism that and I'm just thinking it's
a giant catfish of the film it's like
going on a date wanting to see J.Lo and
then I don't know at the end you see
someone like lizzo for instance I'm just
it's it's completely unnecessary why
can't we just have a film about dolls
the people that made this film have
never seen any of the other Bobby
animals because it's completely
unrelated it's a giant catfish and I
just think you know what it came to no
offense because we're going to come to
you in a moment all again I'm dumb
that's such dumb dweebs
of Love island or something but this is
the problem they're so incompetent and
it's like how can and at the end of the
film they try and say oh but we're all
humans and we're all equal okay but
you've paced you've painted half of
humanity as incompetent halfways so
exactly how does that work done okay you
represent the matriarchy which is
another awful sounding word
um it seems to me what it seems to me
what the movie really wants to do is
just replace the patriarchy with the
matriarchy in other words go from one
thing which every woman apparently
believes is the problem with the world
and flip it round so that the people who
suffer the problem and the oppression
and made to look like downtrodden
imbeciles are men not women I don't
really get that why why is it so awful
this patriarchy syndrome and why replace
the p with an m
but we're like in late stage capitalism
the world's on fire right now uh women
are losing their fundamental rates at
least in my country uh left and right we
still don't make equal pay on the dollar
we're doing emotional labor we're doing
physical labor as the beautiful America
Ferrera uh as you said in her her she
had a moment and her long speech that is
why we want to replace the patriarchy
which is very top down into a more
communal Democratic way of living which
is the matriarchy and back when we had
matriarchies it was more democratic
there I mean Crete of the famous island
of Crete had a matriarchy where they
didn't go to war and that it was
everything was clear so I don't really
see a downside of this I mean right now
so you think just to be clear you think
if women around the world there'll be no
Warfare I I think that it would we have
different ways of dealing with conflict
than men do and if it was a majority
female lead environment we would not be
in a lot of these circumstances
never engaging women never engage in
conflict is that a joke I say we engage
in Conflict engages in Conflict we're
humans but we don't engage in Conflict
the same way and I think this was satire
it was Art I'm sorry if some people
wanted it to be kids movie but the best
art whether it's the Wizard of Oz or or
Barbie is really a reflection of the
times it's a reflection of the struggles
and frankly I don't know I saw you said
that you've never seen a movie like this
when I saw that Marilyn Monroe movie who
was a complicated beautiful artist
genius they made it out to be a I mean
it was Despicable it was an assault on
women so how about most movies out there
do make women feel uncomfortable and my
God it's art have a sense of humor there
was satire it was a you know attacks on
capitalism uh climate change Warfare it
was it fun it was later it was
complicated like women before I bring in
Ken let me just bring in Grace I know
you're not into the whole Barbie thing
particularly but patriarchy you'll
definitely need to right you do think so
into it I'm So Into patriarchy
if you really exist an obvious end point
of the very successful attempt that
we've had within most capitalist
societies for Liberal Elites to
basically take over and commodify the
feminist critique which was a critique
of capitalism this is a massive box
office you know hitting movie made by a
huge multinational corporation that's
going to make loads and loads of money
that also uses like exploitative labor
practices all around the world the
problem is you know it's not like there
was Ariana Huffington famously said the
financial crisis wouldn't have happened
if it had been Lehman sisters instead of
believing brothers that's obviously
completely wrong I personally don't even
buy the idea there are these huge
insurmountable differences between men
and women the problem is capitalism
that's why we have gender inequality
that's why we have racial inequality
that's we have all these different forms
of inequality unless we get you know
that's it that's by taking down their
corporations
that's fine I I have no problem with you
believing that that's fine I'm glad you
have no problem I'm glad we agree that I
have the right to believe what I believe
can we just leave Barbie out of it I
don't mind them making this trash heap
of effect quite hard to leave Bobby out
of it when you're literally dressed like
love yes but let's let's rename the film
to something some pink feminist like
child film let's do that because what
this Bobby film is not Bobby related at
all anyone who's seen any of the Barbie
films any of the Animated Series who's
grown up with it this is not Barbie
related at all Ken is not you know a
half wit Bobby is not ideologically
incoherent in the way that she is in the
film let's just separate the two well
let's bring it let's bring in the
Smokies all right Chris uh Hey first of
all it's really mean so far
I have a historic thing about love
Island which I'm sure is very well let's
put that to one side look it's
incredible you're in this movie thanks
which is now one of the biggest grossing
films in history first of all how does
that feel yeah pretty good yeah I've
been pretty we're on live Island and now
you're in the biggest movie in the world
yeah it's fair not a normal progression
for love Island no no not really yeah
it's pretty mind-blowing and the story
about how you got this is equally
mind-blowing yeah you go to some
premiere of a movie and you end up or
you're not there in your mates are you
end up going to Margot Robbie's after
party yeah and she turns out to be a
massive love Island in fact yeah
including you yeah she knows who you are
yeah and then I started talking about
male genitalia and the rest of History
was this true yeah no I didn't make it
we talked about somebody new with a
micro penis A friend of mine has a micro
penis yeah as in how big I've not called
Rule around next to it peers like I
don't know exactly telling Margaret
Robert it's small tiny it's it's I'd say
inch and then you have a meat for my
very large testicles is that right uh my
dad's best mate has very big bollocks
and he can carry and this is how you
managed to
get inside Margot Robbie's head to end
up playing Kim I don't know that is that
is what happened but I I will say I
panicked I panicked and I just said
whatever games in my head and it was
relevant like people were talking about
penises but we're not here to debate
this this is like so intrigued I found
the most realistic thing it sounds like
one of those stories where it's like oh
yeah my friend needs advice about
something yeah and this is how you
basically get you in the movie right
next thing 18 months later you're in
Barbie I mean Barbie yeah all because of
that conversation all because of micro
penises and Big Balls yeah no you get
there you're one of myriad Kens my
impression of them is they're basically
depicted as a bunch of losers and if if
I made a movie flipping this round and
depicting women the way that this movie
generally depicts me yeah all hell would
break loose do you accept that I accept
that but I think I feel like you're
missing the point so I think everyone's
missing the point a little bit like so
it's a comedy right and we're in very
dangerous territory when we start are
picking out comedy and saying oh you
can't say that you can't say that
because then we're going to live in a
world where commonly not something but
there's a distinct political and social
point they're making yeah about the
patriarchy which is Rand home again and
again again and again what I'm getting
to is is that the overarching comedy
overarching joke of the entire film is
you're you're looking at Barbie which is
played with by children mostly girls and
this is how they play with Barbies and
Ken's Barbie is the primary character
and Ken is the secondary character that
comes in and out a little bit and is
widely disregarded because the girls see
themselves in the Barbie and not so much
the kids
my problem with these this idea that you
go into the real world from Barbie land
wherever all the women are in charge
yeah and the real world something you're
confronted with this vile Place run
completely by men and they're all awful
even down to the depiction of the
company that makes the Barbie dolls
which is so different to the reality of
that company female president for 30
years half the board now women yeah it's
not run by a bunch of Mad Men Executives
as this film wants you to believe there
is no overt sexism from the company
because it was basically run by women I
don't think Mattel would want people to
believe that I think what you're missing
is the fact that it's a joke and a lot a
lot a lot
of the joke no because listen right okay
listen comedy exactly no grow up I
totally agree
and yeah Society still made money what's
wrong with that I totally agree with you
my point is if I made the movie and
flipped it and was mocking women like
this you would be leading the charge I'd
be hung drawn and quartered probably
executed it's the hypocrisy
where you're making a very deliberate
Point promoting feminism and using
patriarch is a stick to be all Mentor
they can bring of otherwise and then if
women come on your show and say oh I've
got a problem with this you say oh shut
up snowflake like that is the whole
debate that we've had in recently it's
like you can't say anything about
anything because you're a snowflake
thing men are being snowflakes
no no you're missing my point you're
totally inside I haven't seen that I'm
sorry I'm not asking for Barbie to be
canceled obviously everyone's enjoying
it but you're asking for my wife and
daughter went to see it in L.A a couple
days ago they loved it right fine my
problem is with the argument it promotes
I'm allowed to criticize that that's
cool free speech right I'm not trying to
silence and I'm allowed to call you a
snowflake for criticizing yes you are
but you're missing the point about why
I'm criticizing him I'm criticizing the
hypocrisy if you flipped it around
Esther if I made a a movie which
lampooned women like this from a very
male dominated position all hell would
break the thing is it is hypocrisy I
take offense of the fact that you think
this is a comedy it wasn't funny at all
and also there is there is something
like this that actually mocks women it's
called a Dave Chappelle special and
every time he comes up with a new
special we need to cancel him because
he's punching down on the poor women the
reality is this film is a giant catfish
and he used the Barbie name to try and
shoehorn this these ideologies into a
Kids film and you can call it a comedy
if that's your standard of entertainment
that's fine and I don't really have a
higher standard of entertainment I watch
Love Island I watch Fast and Furious and
also
how are they selling this family let me
go to make you for this how are they
selling this feminist Utopia I'll tell
you how they're selling it they're
selling it by choosing the hottest woman
in Hollywood Margot Robbie everyone
thinks that male and female and she's
making she produces it I think she's uh
right our production so she's making
tens probably hundreds of millions of
dollars as the hottest woman in
Hollywood in every sense from a movie
which makes our all women are oppressed
by the patriarchy forgive me if I laugh
she's the walking breathing embodiment
of someone who's making the patriarchy
look like a bunch of losers it's a g
no I don't agree with that at all and I
think historically there are a lot of
women who had to use whatever tools were
available to them she is beautiful she's
also a brilliant actor she's also
extremely intelligent she's also well
spoken as are all of the women and men
by the way in that film Ryan Gosling is
not getting you know the attacks the way
she is but that's more that's capitalism
and until capitalism failed which I
think is the patriarchy by the way I
think the patriarchy is capitalism until
it fails people are going to do whatever
they can to survive I mean that is one
point at what point would you have to
accept on behalf of the matriarchy the
patriarchy doesn't really exist anymore
and that basically most women I know are
running rings around blokes and what
point do you admit though you know I
think you're literally in a bubble and
do not open the newspaper because the
way that women are under attack in the
United States right now is jaw-dropping
I mean you would be on an abortion the
ban on women's health clinics uh women
being targeted uh rise in in domestic
violence not to mention that our pay has
not moved in ages there's a declination
in women in leadership even though we
think we should be at as some sort of um
a parody at this point it's the way that
women in the press and in the public are
attacked by online campaigns by
corporations by uh
have you spent even a minute in my
Twitter feed trust me this idea only
women get trolled on Twitter
this is the problem
when we get the commodification of
feminism is that we get this idea that
feminism means like every you know CEO
of every corporation being a woman or
having 50 of women on board that's not
the lived experience of the vast
majority of women you know alive the
vast majority of women actually live in
you know either in very poor countries
where they're denied education or they
live you know in situations where they
experience domestic violence here in the
UK one in three women will experience
sexual assault at some point in their
lives you know that's what life is like
for most working classes can't get rid
of that by just saying oh we're gonna
like you know make a couple of you know
Prime Ministers or or CEOs that's the
problem with liberals you don't think
you don't think young men ever get
assaulted I mean I do but they don't get
assaulted to the extent that women
that's not the point you're like you
know who gets stabbed in the streets is
very rarely women is young men by men
right I think we can agree so there are
different violence is a problem but it's
not there are lots of male victims
violence right I think we didn't say
when it yes we did I said sexual
violence right which is a deep deep
problem in our society yeah it's
actually if you look at it with inside
within and outside the home we'll come
and then what you're talking about kind
of gang violence on the streets and it
happens to women so much and when it's
oh when it's part of a bigger narrative
about racism then it's fine to talk
about violence against women but we're
actually talking about how we tackle
violence against women unless it's a
part of this wider agenda cultural
agenda nobody cares and that's a problem
well I care uh Ken last word to you
I think everyone's just missing the
point oh did it okay it's based it's a
joke Greta go he's done a good job of
navigating a potentially massive
Minefield you're right if it flipped it
would be a different story right
ultimately I'll admit that right but
thank you about a doll that was made in
the night in 1959
but you got to a place
by the way
about women empowerment
of women yeah all right enough virtue
signaling mate you've got you you take
all the boxes I'm gonna end by giving
women what they really want from their
Ken it's this
I'm not busy
he's terrified that's a proper Kim
there's another one here there we go
that's that's heavily photoshopped not
at all I have no words this is the whole
I got a whole Rafters nothing to say
that is terrifying
I'm speechless thank you let's leave it
on that
rendered silent by the glory of my
kingdom uh thank you Chris
congratulations mate all right Margot
Robbie is one of my favorite ad probably
is my favorite actress I met her in
obnoxious party she was fabulous did she
tell you about how she likes Union no we
talked about it Union we talked about
Cricket she's an Australian
unfortunately now right now that's the
last thing I want to talk about is
drinking uh but well at the time there
was no actually series we had a great
conversation lovely woman very talented
couldn't be happy that a woman is making
hundreds of millions of dollars out of
her looks and her Talent uh in the
patriarchy what a miracle how's she
doing it it's really it's incredible
some woman is able to do that break
through this towering sexist Mayhem
which inhibits all women I know
including these two downtrodden
oppressed female creatures in front of
me who I know just never feel they can
even speak unless I let them right
ladies of course
uh Chris great to see congratulations
seriously cheers from love Island to the
world's biggest movie that is directory
I never thought I'd ever witnessed so
you can't slay this anymore I can't
sleep
anymore an oscar-worthy meteor Christ
it's amazing and I genuinely thank you
I'm sensored next from pink to Green
both labor and the conservatives go cold
on their environmental policies after
mixed results and violations is it
really their unpopular leaders should be
taking the heat the dean Doris joins me
live after the break
[Music]
thank you
good evening I'm Piers Morgan I'm
censored in New York City tonight up
here's Morgan uncensored in Kiev Ukraine
tonight on Piers Morgan on special
edition tonight a special edition of
Piers Morgan uncensored Martina
navratulations do you believe you can
win this war so are you gonna run again
I think a lot of people are going to be
very happy yes I feel betrayed they're
trying to force you out yes not only the
coach but the other two or three guys
there around all these protesting just
don't get it many of them don't it's not
slightly patronizing
I would call it beautiful out the window
do you think we should have psychiatric
assessments
did you keep quiet I'm trying to read
the book
thanks bear and Chuck it where it
belongs in the bed
[Music]
why isn't someone
else with the castle
it's from that much cushier jail that
Elaine Maxwell agreed to be interviewed
for the very first time I obviously wish
I'd never met him you're shaking
British prime minister
party can certainly win the next
election can we yes
can we this is the royalty question is
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they've bent the rules to give them the
Visa or lied on the visa application
form and therefore got it
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
a woman is given to the man in marriage
Andrew You're simply wrong I've been a
terrible liar that's true I mean would
you be prepared to say that I've been a
terrible liar are you sorry you said
that
I think it matters you should be
absolutely not you should be interview
adjourned
[Music]
which is your favorite nickname that
Trump's giving us Rhonda sanctimonious
or meatball Rock I've seen you clown
Tommy Fury so please go easy on me bro
please go easy you weren't asked to give
evidence to the grand jury I have
nothing to hire I'm the only one that
has been telling the truth since you had
to come up against a team that had a
Russian player would you shake that your
chance no chance it's life and death
This Is War Pass Morgan
what went wrong she said well I've only
got two years and I said you'll have two
months if you carry on like this what's
your response to him the whole nation
deserves to know what happened you don't
drink never taken drugs you're stinking
Rich should we be concerned
real opinions real debate is about you
and your opinions if you're thinking
about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that was a joke
[Music]
welcome back to business organizations
at the front page of today's Times
newspaper which is an interesting
dusting position Tory Retreat from Green
policies to woo voters it says thanks to
a startling image of tourist fleeing a
wildfire in roads fires are raging
across several parts of Greece forcing
many tourists and locals to evacuate
following weeks of extreme heat across
the world but both of Britain's leading
parties the pigeons decided that
unraveling green policy could be a vote
winner PM Rishi sunax is as a recovery
plan up to two bruising by election
defeats they were party meanwhile is
blaming London mezali cars
anti-pollution policy the failing to win
Boris Johnson's old Seaton Uxbridge so
there's any doubts that Euless was the
reason that we lost the by-election in
Uxbridge and I have said we should
reflect on this including the mayor I've
spoken to him as you would expect and so
there will be that reflection
so it's a green agenda worth trading for
an electoral Band-Aid or is it merely
covering up a popularity crisis for both
leaders I'm joined by conservative MP
and talk to you presenter Nadine Doris
and the daily mirrors associate editor
Kevin McGuire so Kevin before we get
into the Weeds on this
pollution right I know this Elite Khan's
policy is not proved very popular
probably because the way it's been
executed and it doesn't quite work I
gotta say that on pollution in London
I'm a hundred percent behind him and
I'll tell you why for the last five
years I thought I had really bad hay
fever every year turned out it was all
pollution I got four air purifiers in my
house I shut the windows I'd check an
app every morning only go out when it's
reasonable and as a result I've had zero
symptoms when the pollen Count's
apparently been raging and people have
been suffering from hay fever I'm a
complete convert I found out that 12 1
in 12 people in Kensington and Chelsea
Borough die from pollution related
illness out shocked and I'm also shocked
by the benefit to my health by taking
pollution more seriously yeah if it was
a virus causing uh so many deaths 40 000
people a year dying
through that exactly the government
would really be reacting opposition
parties would be piling in but I think
because they're individual deaths
they're almost ignored although there
was a case last year a coroner found a
young girl had died of pollution look
the plan in London is to get the
dirtiest cars off the road it's fewer
than one in ten in those outlying areas
now I understand you're a cost of living
crisis while some people will clearly
kick back against that I understand it I
think the fear is more widespread
because people don't realize you could
have a petrol car 16 years old and you
won't have to pay this 12 pound 50 a day
charge you can have a diesel eight years
old and you won't have to pay this this
charger charging is crude no question
about it but we have to clean air it's
not just about global warming it is
about the air see I I didn't I do think
there are lots of issues around this
whole green debate but on this issue of
pollution I do think to deep Khan's
heart is in the right place I was really
shocked by the impact of my health that
I had year after year after year until I
took pollution more seriously and it was
pollution I completely agree with you
and in fact I think what it demonstrates
this this sudden this very sudden
conversion of both Party leaders to
sadly paddling back from these green
policies and Net Zero particularly it
just shows a positive ambition they are
they're scared as a result of what
happened last week with the buyer
elections nobody was really a winner in
any of those by-elections they're scared
and they they've actually seized on what
happened in Uxbridge and think this is
the populist Ray wave which is riding
through Westminster right now we need to
jump on it if it was you less that's
going to work in the rest of the country
and of course it won't and you know if
anybody under the age of 40 kids in
school today this is what they care
about they care about Net Zero and and
policies which benefit the environment
for the very reasons you're articulated
mainly to do with health and to do the
future with the future of the planet but
it's um it is it's a pretty tragic State
of Affairs that we find ourselves in
when a few days after by-election it is
the the Euler's policy which is
interpreted yeah and I thought that's a
very disappointed from Kirsten and I'm
disappointed by Richardson about this
you've got to take these issues
seriously I think a lot of the problem
is they over promise they set the
targets they can't be hit actually we
know we've got to move to a place yeah
right where we are less reliant on
fossil fuels we've got move to cleaner
air yeah so how are we going to do this
well we don't lose tons of jobs and it
doesn't cost everyone money they haven't
got that's the calculation yeah and how
you can transition uh you know the most
prosperous and easiest way possible has
got to be the goal but you know what do
Party leaders really stand for this they
stand for winning the election right and
that's what we're that's what we're
seeing whether these by-elections tell
you about where we really are here
because Kia stama can't have been that
happy yeah but hang on if you're curious
stormy you've overturned the 20 000
majority and so you have in North
Yorkshire the liberal Democrats
but the direction of travel the momentum
in British politics was seen in Selby
which labor won and Summit and through
which the liberal Democrats took for the
Tories not in Uxbridge where there was a
specific local issue in outer London and
I think I think
and you don't defeat from the Jaws
across 650 constituents where do you
think we are politically as a country
right now do you think it's just is it
inevitable that label will win the next
election no actually it's not and it's
not for a very important reason which
most people seem to I think just don't
acknowledge I think evangela Arena was
leader of the labor party that would be
a far more
dead third of happening than it is with
Kirsten but there is no love for kirst
armor and I remember being out in the
doorstep in 97 you know as a
conservative people hated I got spat on
the doorstep but it's not me now and the
reason why they hated us was they didn't
hate us so much as love Tony Blair it
was totally You could argue in 19. You
could argue in 92 Neil Kennett was more
popular and more until it was about two
days then yeah but he's lost in 87. I
mean I remember 92 and I never thought
labor would no no no no I think the
reason a labor Victory isn't inevitable
they were further ahead at this stage
it's because the next elections not 70
or 80 weeks away isn't it and as Harold
Wilson said A week is a long time in
politics and as Harold MacMillan the
conservative prime minister said events
said to me on this very show I am
quitting as a conservative Member of
Parliament and here you are we must play
the Clinton
are you actually going to quit as an MP
yeah I've resigned there's no way back
some people think you may you may change
your mind that you're being a bit
hot-headed no yeah so that was June
you're still here you're still a
conservative MP anyway moving swiftly on
so you just whispered quietly shall I
announce what I'm doing go on there come
on no I'll do that on my own show thank
you very much wow so so are you staying
come here are you staying Neil Kennedy
no no no no you are definitely
definitely I you'll hear you'll hear all
about it soon on the Friday night open
the dean show which which is not back on
until September
was actually Riding High until the
Sheffield rally which was about three
days
I think I'd symbolize what was going on
people had doubts about him
unfortunately but we'll see I think it's
I still think it's everything to play
for I really do I think if Rishi soon
that got a bit of steam behind him and
the economy starts to come back quite
strongly Anything could happen there's a
lot conversely if neither of those two
things happen you can get Flatline I
think the iron Tory mood has taken also
have you seen Barbie yet you two no I'm
going tomorrow night you are yeah I'm
outraged the way they're using my body
double as Ken
I think I heard it was your brain double
oh uh
do you like Bobby
it'll be fine I'm neither but I haven't
seen it you think you're being
suppressed by the patriarchy exactly
exactly my point you didn't have to say
a word
to your announcement on your show on
Friday yeah it says the next pop rockers
The 1975 calls outrage in Malaysia are
taking a public stand on stage for gay
rights or copies of the Quran being
burned in Sweden does Free Speech have
the right to offend even the most firmly
hell believes Sam Harris will be will be
with me to discuss that
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to physical someone just
tweeted me asking how I'm feeling about
the cricket but how do you think I'm
feeling about the cricket
England and Australia
dead and buried and then the rain ruined
it so obviously I feel sickened
absolutely sickened but thank you for
asking an angry diplomatic route between
Sweden a number of Islamic majority
countries has erupted over the weekend
it comes out of copies of the Quran were
burned and stamped on as part of protest
by an Iraqi Asylum Seeker in Stockholm
Pakistani protesters held anti-sweden
protester retaliation and Iraqi
protesters Set Fire to the Swedish
Embassy in Baghdad instead of once again
raised a debate around whether Free
Speech always has the right to offend
even the most firmly held beliefs let's
ask my special guest the author
neuroscientist and host of The Making
Science sense podcast Sam Harris Sam
Harris great to have you on Facebook
when I said to him
yeah hey peers good to see you this line
between religious beliefs freedom of
speech is there a line that should be
drawn
well ultimately no I mean I think it's
we just have speech right we just have a
contest of ideas and when ideas actually
matter we really need our best ideas to
be operative ideas about human Freedom
ideas about
political tolerance equality among
people I mean these are these are ideas
that we really can't afford to
compromise on and I would say that that
extends to just a rational understanding
of the way the world works right so we
can't
compromise on scientific truth or
historical truth or journalistic truth
ultimately
um and I mean I think there's a there's
certainly scope for civility and
pragmatism and politeness and picking
your battles but the general picture
here is that there's there's only one
religion on Earth at the moment that
imagines that even non-members of the
religion
should be obliged to live by its
strictures right so they you know all
religions are certainly most religions
have some concept of blasphemy they
don't like it when their their sacred
objects or sacred places or sacred
figures or are defamed but
there really is there is only only one
religion that will murder you for doing
anything like that and and really
without any with a full clarity of
conscience among
uh you know even majorities in many
communities uh will will call for for
the murder of a blasphemers or idolaters
or you know other others who try to
introduce the sacred tenets of the faith
even if they're not part of the faith
and and that religion is of course Islam
in its various forms and so that's a way
there is a contest between this kind of
fundamentalist intolerance and modernity
and it you know if we were dealing with
the Christians of the 14th century well
we would have a similar contest with
Christians but we're not happily and and
with Islam I hear that opening burning
copies of the Quran I personally I'm a
massive believer in free speech I
campaign about it on the show all the
time but openly uh burning copies of
religious but like the Quran I don't I
think that does cross a line I don't
think you should defend that necessarily
using Free Speech as the defense should
we
well I don't I don't defend it as a
matter of taste I'm not advocating that
people burn the Quran but I think we
should be politically free to burn any
book right we should we should just
acknowledge that books are books created
by people right and the idea that
some considerable number of people in
the Muslim world
see otherwise right and would imagine
that that a specific book is more
important than any
specific person or a group of people
that's just it's just upside down
ethically and politically in a way that
we just have to recognize it's just you
know
I mean just take it you know leave it
leave aside the burning of books just
take take just the the disrespect for
religious Traditions you have a a
Broadway play the musical like the Book
of Mormon right which was very funny and
which most Mormons didn't much care for
but what they did to protest that was
they took out ads rather cheeky ads in
playbill the the magazine that you get
when you walk into a Broadway Theater
and this was all in good fun and it was
really you know they were they tried to
recruit from Mormonism within play a
bill you know and it was it was
delightful and that was a and yet they
they voiced their opposition to the
basic project that was poking fun at
their religion but the the the the thing
to notice of course is that a a book of
Islam Broadway musical that poked
similar fun at Islam would have been and
would still be Unthinkable and not just
in Baghdad or or you know Kandahar but
in New York right I mean the the the the
security concerns that would attend such
a production would it would be
excruciating and that disparity is it
should be intolerable to us what about
this uh story
um where the band The 1975 who a rock
band they go to Malaysia they know that
Malaysia has anti-gay laws but they
accept a booking to go and perform on
stage there and then the lead singer
Matty Healy decides to kiss his band
member male band member on stage in a
deliberate Act of defiance so it turned
out that he'd done something similar in
2019 in Dubai which also has anti-gay
laws uh so it wasn't his first journey
on this rodeo and it also came after
inflammatory comments he'd May which
were perceive to be homophobic and
defensive a few months ago he came out
on a podcast so it was a bit of
hypocrisy there but the basic principle
of going to a country like Malaysia and
deliberately fled immigrantly breaching
the conventions of that country is that
a sensible thing to do you're allowed to
do it obviously you can do it and get
all the credit you may want from Twitter
for doing it but should people do that
well I don't know I think you have to
view that on a case-by-case basis I
think there's an argument for not going
to places where there's such religious
intolerance that you just don't you
don't want to support uh anything about
the the the Norms in that Society or I
suppose you can go oh as this band did
and protest those norms and and
hopefully make a point that lands
politically in that society and I really
I think that's just a judgment call and
it you I could go either way with that
yeah but I I mean the larger point to
make here though is that
we can't afford we the West we you know
secular societies diverse societies
pluralistic societies globally speaking
can't conform to the religious taboos of
any specific Community I mean right now
if you go on chat gpt4 and ask it to
tell you a joke about Jesus it will tell
you a joke about Jesus and if you ask
her to tell you a joke about Buddha it
will tell you a joke about Buddha and
they're not good jokes but it'll tell
you jokes but if you ask it to tell you
a joke about Muhammad it will refuse
because of the religious sensitivities
of Muslims and if you ask it about that
incoherence
um it will basically become as evasive
as Andrew Tate was when you interviewed
him well you know I was actually going
to reference I was going to reference
another interview actually which Richard
Dawkins when I asked him about speaking
out like this in the way that you've
been doing just now and his reply was
really quiet I found it quite chilling
actually take a look
are you worried about me do you get
threats because of the positions you've
taken on some of these things yeah
when you saw what happened to salmon
rush to you
didn't send a shutter three
are you saying no you don't want to talk
about it or yes
right I mean that's interesting in
itself because is it
there are areas which you would prefer
not to discuss
I should have said that before we
started yeah no but instantly I I'm I
think it's sad that you can't
I don't think anything should be off
limits in interviews with people like
you
I mean I thought that was really
interesting that someone like Dawkins
just would not answer out of fear it
turned out
yeah well I would have to ask Richard
what his motive was there I I can
imagine it might not have been fear but
just the the pragmatic concern that
acknowledging the the threat landscape
is in some way unwise right that you're
actually increasing your security
concerns by admitting that you have them
on some level but this is this is just
plain for everyone to see that there is
this
this vast difference between criticizing
Islam however peripherally however I
mean even on the tiniest points you know
to just surely just depicting the
prophet Prophet Muhammad in a cartoon
right we're naming a a teddy bear uh or
a bear in a South Park episode uh
Muhammad right it's just this is the
kind of thing that can get embassies
burned in a dozen cities right this is
this is just there's nothing like this
coming from any other religion and that
difference is important right I'm not
saying that people should go out of
their way to criticize Islam or any
other religion necessarily though I
think when when push comes to shove we
have to just acknowledge that
we need good reasons for believing the
our most important beliefs and and
figuring out you know how to how to
organize our societies right so it's
just one when people are resting on
Dogma we should be increasingly
impatient with that and we would be
impatient with astrologers if they were
trying to change our our laws and our
politics too
uh but with Islam we just we have to
recognize that
okay it deserves all of the respect that
every other religion does and all of the
the patients that every other religion
does in a pluralistic and diverse
Society but no more right and we see you
know we're now we're not we're literally
building it into our most advanced
artificial intelligence this this double
standard and and we're doing it out of
fear right we can call it religious
tolerance but it is just fear it's just
you know we have been successfully
bullied into having a double standard
and it's um
uh it's dysfunctional it's ultimately
dangerous I mean the problem for Solomon
Rushdie was that there were there
weren't ten thousand Salman rushdies the
very next day as there should have been
uh and that's why he had this asymmetric
risk for for decades and and ultimately
suffered a terrible attack uh we we
should stand shoulder to soldier with
someone and
um and I I'm not saying Richard wasn't
doing that Richard is an extraordinarily
Brave public intellectual and he's been
on the front lines of this debate for
decades
somehow it's great to talk to you I
really appreciate it uh your podcast is
making sense I appreciate you coming on
the show thank you very much
yeah take care
well assistant next a small tribute to a
broadcasting great
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
coming up on the talk Greek holiday
chaos as thousands of Brits are stranded
on Islands devastated by wildfires the
Met police are slammed for handcuffing
and wrongly arresting a woman over a bus
fare and Twitter rebrands as EX in Elon
musk's latest shake-up that's all at
nine o'clock
[Applause]
well in case you didn't think you could
see anything worse than the Barbie movie
that's Victoria Beckham On karaoke in
Miami with her husband uh murdering a
Spice Girls song which may explain why
she hasn't been on tour with them for
many years am I wrong you too did you
hear some magic I didn't I just drunk
and having a good time aren't they I
don't know what you're like singing when
you've had a few drinks brilliant true
story I once got offered a recording
contract and a Barbados karaoke bar at
4am on American record company executive
as I was stripped to the waist with a
bandana singing Guns and Roses version
Live and Let Die sober I wasn't
I don't know about him but he was
serious on on the spot wanted to sign me
um Twitter is going to be rebranded as X
by Elon Musk your thoughts I just think
Elon musk's tenure owning and briefly
leading Twitter has been a total
disaster platforms last time you had a
business called X he rebranded it as
PayPal I mean he's made himself
staggeringly wealthy SpaceX has become
the most successful private space
company in the world and Twitter's
Revenue Tesla is gigantic Twitter I have
been marketing marketing Revenue has a
marketing incomes always declined
dramatically since he's taken over there
have been millions of people who left
the platform you now
I mean there's a difference ultimately
between running a social media company
and running you know a large
manufacturing organization Elon Musk
seems to have kind of basically got a
bit of hubris I don't really agree I
sort of buy into must in totality Watson
all I think he's a he's a kind of he's a
genius and with Geniuses Comes This
slightly mad stuff yes but I do think he
is too close to this Twitter project
he's on Twitter Twitter we know all his
views because of Twitter yeah and he you
know I think he's too involved to really
be able to step back and see what
everyone else I bet he cracks it I I'm
not I bet you in two years time we look
back and Elon Musk will have turned
around no he is because you saw the
stuff about how it was a pathetic the
way he was like twigging the algorithm
to make history
basically seems like he's the the
power's gone to his head he can't see
anything clear anymore and he's like I
think if I had 260 billion dollars of
power go to my head just like what just
FYI
billion dollars not yet but these early
days uh thank you I on the other hand
would manage it perfectly you'd love a
lot of money all good socialists great
to see you both thank you both very much
indeed I want to end on a very sad note
uh the BBC news anchor and Brilliant
journalist legendary foreign
correspondent George alagaya has died of
bowel cancer he thought it for nearly a
decade with Incredible courage he was an
extraordinary inspiration to so many
people one of the most beloved people in
the news industry a lot of friends of
mine at BBC in mourning for him today
and we share that sense of great loss
both for us our industry and for the
country I want to thank George for
everything he did for journalism and for
news that's it for me whatever you're up
to keep it uncensored you know
[Music]
good evening I'm Peters Morgan I'm
censored in New York City tonight up
here's Morgan uncensored in Kiev Ukraine
tonight on Piers Morgan Special Edition
from cancer tonight a special edition
appears more than uncensored Martina
navratulations making me cry again do
you believe you can win this war so are
you gonna run again I think a lot of
people are going to be very happy yes I
feel betrayed they're trying to force
you out yes not only the coach but the
other two or three guys there around
well these protesting just don't get it
many of them don't it's not slightly
patronizing
I would call it beautiful out the window
do you think we should have psychiatric
assessments
did you keep quiet I'm trying to read
the book
it takes bear and Chuck it where it
belongs in the bin
[Music]
why isn't someone on the one on them
it's from that much cushier jail that
Elaine Maxwell agreed to be interviewed
for the very first time I obviously wish
I'd never met him you're shaking your
head the British people are up in arms
Boris Johnson is out as British prime
minister the conservative party can
certainly win the next election can we
yes
this is the Royal team question is did
he say yes I have taken drugs and they
bent the rules to give them the Visa or
lied on the visa application form and
therefore got it
foreign